Diane why don't you remind them who the
nominees for Best Picture are happy to
do that check thank you very much
okay babble Alejandro Gonzalez Inarritu
John yeah
John Carrick and Steve :
producers the departed Graham King
producer letters from iwo jima Clint
Eastwood Steven Spielberg Robert Lorenz
producers Little Miss Sunshine David T
friendly Peter Sara and mark turtle top
producers and finally the Queen Anne
Tijeras Christine Langan and Tracy
c-word producers
and the Oscar goes to the departing
Martin Scorsese calls The Departed the
first movie he has ever done with a plot
Wow who to be standing here where the
Queen of England yesterd it er mean is
pretty incredible to be standing here
when Martin Scorsese one is Oscar is
such a joy such a joy
now I have to read something well I want
to thank Warner Brothers amazing guys to
work with Alan horn Jeff robinov Donlin
a huge thanks to Kevin McCormick who
takes my 15 calls a day every day all
the cast and crew that Marty just
mentioned you know I've been lucky
enough to work with this guy four times
now and last year I was lucky enough to
produce two movies the departed and
Blood Diamond I just want to tell you
from the bottom of my heart that's me
mr. Leonardo DiCaprio what amazing
performances he does every single time
every time I Love You Man
I can't really stand here and not thank
Jack I mean to watch Miley direct Jack
we'll talk about that later I want to
thank all my family or my friends bill
Monahan
what a great screenplay what a great to
being played Rick you've been there for
years everyone my kids are at the back
there Haley and Sammy you're awesome
my family my sister Erica a lot of
patience with me thank you so much and I
just want to say to everyone that knows
me calling my business kind of Dennis
who spent every day on set with me I
know I drove him nuts thank you and
thanks to everyone thank you so much